MARTINA BALAGOVIC: Hi.
Welcome back.
Today's problem is about solving
homogeneous linear systems,
A*x equals 0, but it's also
an introduction to the next
lecture and next
recitation section,
which are going to be about
solving non-homogeneous linear
systems, A*x equals b.
The problem is fill
the blanks type.
And it says the set S of all
points with coordinates x, y,
and z, such that x minus 5y plus
2z equals 9 is a blank in R^3.
It is in a certain relation
to the other blank S_0
of all the points
with coordinates x, y,
and z that satisfy the
following linear equation,
x minus 5y plus 2z equals 0.
After we solve this,
we have the second part
of the problem, which
says all points of x have
a specific form, x,
y, z equals blank, 0,
0, plus some parameter
times blank, 1,
0 plus some other parameter
times blank, 0, 1.
And we need to fill
out all six blanks.
Now you should pause the
video, fill in the blanks,
and then come back and
see some pretty pictures
that I prepared for you.
And we're back.
So you probably picked this
up in lectures already.
If you have a three-dimensional
space with three degrees
of freedom, and put in
one constraint, so put
in one equation,
you get something
that has two degrees
of freedom, something
that's two-dimensional.
If this equation is linear,
rather than quadratic
or cubic or exponential,
this something
is something
two-dimensional and flat.
Something two-dimensional and
flat in R^3 is also called
a plane, or a two-plane.
Similarly, S_0 is also a plane.
Now, what's the relation
between S and S_0
if they're given by
these two equations?
Well first let's look at the
general positions in which two
planes in R^3 can be.
First one is that they're
intersecting along a line.
What's going to happen here is
that all points on this plane
are points whose
coordinates satisfy
the equation of this plane.
The points in this
plane are points
whose coordinates satisfy
the equation of this plane.
And the points on the line
are points whose coordinates
satisfy the system of this
equation and this equation.
The other position in
which two planes can be
is that they're not intersecting
at all, that they're parallel.
So let's start by trying
to find this line here.
The equation of one plane is
x minus 5y plus 2z equal 9.
The equation of the other one
is x minus 5y plus 2z equals 0.
Now you can just
look at it and see
how many solutions
it's supposed to have,
or you can try
doing elimination,
and after one step
of elimination
get 0 equals 9,
which never happens.
There cannot exist numbers
x, y, and z such that this
combination of them produces
0, and the same combination
of them produces 9
at the same time.
So this red line
here doesn't exist,
and the situation of these two
planes S and S_0 is this one,
they're parallel.
So let's add the word
parallel in here.
And let's move on to the
other half of the problem.
The other half said all points
of S have this specific form.
Now let me call
this point here P_0.
If all points of
S have this form,
we can plug in any
parameter c_1 and c_2 here
and we're going to get
a point of the plane.
So in particular, we can plug
in c_1 and c_2 equal to 0.
What we get then is
that the point (x, y, z)
equals P_0 is a point of
the plane S. So P_0 is in S.
What do we know
about the point P_0?
Well the fact that
it's in S means
that its coordinates, x
minus 5y plus 2z equal 9.
That's the equation
of S. But we also
know that y and z
are equal to 0 and 0.
Solving this system we get that
the x-coordinate of this point
P_0 is 9, and we
can just add 9 here.
So we just have two
blanks left to fill.
Before we'll fill
them, let me show you
a picture that I drew here.
So we have these two planes,
S_0 and S, which are parallel.
They're given by
these equations.
And the plane S_0
has a point 0 in it,
because the equation is x
minus 5y plus 2z equals 0,
so it satisfied by 0, 0, 0.
The plane S has this point P_0
in it, which is (9, 0, 0)--
we just figured this out.
And there's this vector
connecting one plane
to the other.
Now, since those two
planes are parallel
and there's this vector going
between them, what we can see
is that a good way
to get any point in S
is to go to any point in S_0
and go up by this vector.
Now let me write this down.
What I just said is that any
point in S is of the form--
use this vector to go up--
plus any point in S_0.
And if we compare this
to this expression here,
we also get P_0 plus
this linear combination.
So this here has to
be a point in S_0.
Now we're left with a question
of how to parameterize
all points in S_0.
What are all the points in
S_0, and what does this problem
have to do with solving
homogeneous linear equations?
Well, let me write
this equation of S_0
in a slightly different way.
Let me write it as 1, minus
5, 2, x, y, z, equals 0.
And let me think of this
as a matrix of the system.
It's a very tiny matrix,
but it's a matrix.
And think of it as a
matrix dot a vector equals
0, and trying to find all
solutions of the system.
Well let's do row
reductions here.
It's already as upper triangular
as these tiny matrices get.
This is a pivot.
So we have a pivot variable x.
These are free
variables, y and z.
And if you remember how
to solve these systems,
for each free variable we
get one particular solution.
So we get one particular
solution when we plug in y is 1
and all the other
free variables are 0.
Plugging it in here, we
just get that in that case,
x-- so we get x minus 5 times
1 plus 2 times 0 equals 0.
So x is equal to 5.
And the other solution
is for setting
all free variables
equal to 0, except z
which we set equal to 1.
And then we get x minus 5 times
0 plus 2 times 1 equals 0.
So we get that in this
case, x equals minus 2.
And any solution of this system
is going to be of the form
some constant times this plus
some other constant times this.
And if we walk back to
our original problem here,
we see that these parameters,
these numbers here,
have been set up exactly so that
we can just take these numbers
and just copy them
over, 5 and minus 2.
And this is the general form
of any point of the plane S.
It's go up this vector, and
then add a point in S_0,
in the parallel plane that
passes through the origin.
This finishes our problem.
But what I would
encourage you to do now
is to go on to the next lecture,
watch the next recitation
video, and then come
back here and think
about what is it that
we really did here
on this half of the board.
Thank you.